Have you ever looked up from your phone
and realized an hour vanished? Welcome
to digital quicksand, where our
attention has become the most valuable
currency in the world. Your smartphone
isn't just a tool. It's an attention
vampire that's hijacking your brain's
reward system. It's like we've
voluntarily installed a 247 distraction
machine in our pockets. Here's the
shocking reality. It takes 23 minutes to
fully refocus after a single
notification. That's not just wasted
time. It's creating attention residue
that prevents deep work. That
notification about your cousin's lunch
just cost you half an hour of productive
time. The myth of multitasking is
crushing your productivity by 40%. Your
brain doesn't juggle tasks, it rapidly
switches between them, paying a mental
toll each time. But there's hope. Train
your focus like a muscle. Work with your
brain's natural ultradian rhythms and
practice single tasking to enter the
flow state where you can be 500% more
productive. Your brain is not a machine.
It's a high performance organism that
needs strategic maintenance because in
the end, your life becomes what you pay
attention to. Make it count.